[Music]
in have better morals news submitted by
I love you
here's why we learn more from trusting
people than by being suspicious of them
because we flowe up and then they
haven't lived in LA but go on
so pretty much this whole article here
they're talking about how when you trust
someone you end up learning more and you
end up learning how to trust so if
you're constantly people make sense for
sure no it's just like for example if
you're one of the examples that they use
here it's like if your friend um is
asking if you could come sleep over if
you don't trust your friend and you say
no then you'll never know if your friend
was trustworthy like it's like you have
to get robbed to find out if you would
have gotten robbed right that's stupid
so they're saying that test
[ __ ] like without going so far
I wouldn't I wouldn't put my butthole at
risk like that well this whole piece
here is just talking about how you end
up becoming like smarter if you end up
trusting more so every society there are
a lot more benefits for you to be more
trusting rather than being skeptical of
people and just not just Rob for not
suit for why but now you learn not to
how not to get sued right right right
right right so it's worth it that's
right it's like the Marshall you both
are the more like Calvin I think that
like life experiences are great but I'm
just like it sucks when you're going
through I don't know why did you get
sued can we no I signed an NDA so I
can't like talk about the person but
yeah so anyway so then they are also
talking about how there were these
experiments conducted similar to trust
games where participants would interact
with each other before making the
decision to transfer money or not to the
other and so the most trusting
participants were better at figuring out
who would be trustworthy or who they
would transfer money or should transfer
money so then they found out
that there was the same pattern and so
people who trust like for example people
who trust the media more are more
knowledgeable about politics and news
and same thing with people I trust more
or they trust science then they end up
becoming more scientifically literate
and so it's just like if you continue to
close yourself off from things and not
trust anything you're not gonna really
educate educate yourself and not just in
terms of like like interpersonal
relationships the difference between
being open and trusting because like
being open like I can listen to the
media but I don't know about trust you
know like they're mixing belief right so
like do I believe in the media or do I
believe and trust what they're saying am
I open to the information exactly
instead of shutting it out completely
I've been open to the information don't
you guys think that the normal person is
most likely to channel into whatever
they trust rather than like just have an
open mind and see every other point you
know the average person yeah and I think
that's what's wrong is that I think that
people need to listen to all different
sources and then form their own opinion
rather than just tuned into like one
source and like they're telling you this
other source is lying so then you don't
even listen to that source because you
trust this one so much yeah cuz to me
Trust sounds a little bit like blind
faith yeah I think trust needs to be
earned I wasn't talking about
relationships hmm
I mean yeah like that one friend example
though the way I do it is I give
everyone trust till you break it then
you never get it again
thousand dollars uh yeah yeah and if you
never gave it back I just be like dang
he's a piece of [ __ ]
you know but yeah there's a there I
always say like Trust is built in stages
right like you never [ __ ] on the first
day unless it's really good right you
you never you're not really supposed to
but how many great things come out of
that but anyways um so like you might be
okay with a thousand bucks right right
right
because you kind of know Bart but what
if he asks you
a million dollars if I had it and like I
know your character enough that I would
give it to you yeah that it sits in
stages because your question because
your thing was if I had it right so
right I don't have it people like like
let's say if you have ten gold rings
right and if he acts asks you to bottle
one you'll be like sure because you have
ten yeah so you can test that friendship
with that one thing and if it goes away
it's fine
what do you what if he asks you for all
ten that's different but think about it
this way one gold ring is still worth a
lot like that still something else but
what I'm saying is it's worth to the to
test the relationship versus all your
gold rings if you give up all your gold
rings now that's gonna make you sweat
cuz you're like [ __ ] that make the right
choice yeah but you never give
everything away not even in the trust
thing is it can easily come off as that
yeah and when you when you tell someone
to trust someone to me it's done in
stages not blind faith yeah cuz the
article seems like let them give
everyone all ten rings okay yeah but it
should be then stages like okay I heard
this on the media I checked my sources
this media is pretty accurate
the next thing this media tells me I'm
gonna believe it a little bit more a
little bit more a little bit more
because like Scientology people just
blindly trust them and make it all of
everything taken away from them so like
yeah so I think it's all about being
open and giving trust in stages Trust is
hard yeah but I enjoy being curious and
open and trying to learn and understand
and make my own decisions after I get
almost all the information anyway if you
were about to get into a new
relationship do you think like do you
just trust or are you like oh I'm just
not gonna let you wall with your friends
until you show me you can go out with
your friends and lose it right like that
kind of trust like a relationship you
kind of just trust until they [ __ ] up
and then you're like oh wait now I got a
make sure you know I think it still goes
with the stage is part of it because I
mean you trust up until the point like
you're not giving it all you know I mean
you're kind of testing more than you're
like you're like what do they do if
they're allowed to if they go out with
their friends and stuff and then as you
of always a couple or two it's another
point you are trusting enough though and
the B do that I
guess I wouldn't get to I wouldn't call
it trust because to me it's more like a
tent and like I'm sampling and seeing if
we gel together the article is like
approaching it as though like I guess
for you you're labeling it as like
sampling but for them they're calling it
like trust them enough to even give them
that goal because Trust to me means like
if I go like this you catch me every
time true that's trust and I don't know
if I trust like a brand new relationship
I'm like I want to but like I don't know
in her before yeah cuz you trust it so
like if like they go out enough times
and I see like oh wow they really have
my back or they really like care about
me or they show it and so a them I think
I could fall now romantic or
platonically sure think oh those like in
different ways yeah but we're talking
about romantic romantic I think uh don't
forget evening in the beginning of the
relationship I just trust a million
thousand percent me as five they're
really like like we at the minute I go I
think I want to pursue this it's like
here's my social security number on my
credit card every single be and I try
and I trust completely and I'm like but
if you [ __ ] me over I will [ __ ] kill
you in your entire [ __ ] family so be
very careful with yeah with all this
information careful with my heart yeah
yeah but it's hard for me to be like
steps when it comes to relationship and
business dealing that thing is different
but with like with friends I I just go
this is my [ __ ] heart everyone has
keys to my house I don't give a [ __ ]
about now yeah and that's why you have
more meaningful relationships and
experiences cuz you're like [ __ ] and
then if you fall you're like well that
hurt but at least like I got something
like you learned something along the way
that you guys get to that point where
you go okay all my trust right so
leading up to that there is a test yeah
up until that point where you go we're
together
boom I trust like the top your face yeah
yeah yeah for sure
so I think that stage is where people
kind of like never leave even after they
get into a relationship yeah so they're
testing and then they say yes and then
they're still testing yeah you test
forever I don't think I ever stopped
testing
oh I stopped testing lightning like it's
so exhausting no it's just
so like it's like initial like maybe
like one month where I'm like I don't
know do they like me as much as I like
them and then I have to see signs of it
and then when I really see signs of it I
mean it has to come within the first
couple weeks or else like why would I
say it right but what I mean it's like
an every aspect of our relationship like
not just faithfulness by like do you
trust 1,000 long I guess yeah I just
answered my own question you trust a
thousand precisely you're married
because one says everything yeah once
you get past that stage I'm Marian I'm
not married I get it he's buying all
your friends flowers it's like the point
where you feel weird about something
like this doesn't see ya why is your
mouth on that guy's dick are you
cheating over friends oh cool all right
yeah yeah yeah yeah I didn't turns like
that yeah but I think it's like up until
that point where something weird happens
in your life man it's not normal there
you gotta talk about it question it see
how it works
past that I'll talk about it I go
investigate coming back to this article
here like that's pretty much what
they're saying if I have to trust enough
to even like begin and like having that
opportunity where you can learn
something from someone or from the topic
but if you're completely closed off to
and you're just like I'll never trust
that person they'll never enter they
will never learn you'll never grow you
know learn how to trust if you never
tried totally I think yeah I guess I
just labeled it differently like it's me
that's just being open I agree though it
takes a little bit of time to trust all
of us don't think that the word trust is
defined well in this article like the
way that we see it yeah I would call it
openness or like you might be wondering
yeah approaching risky things with
optimistic points of view mm-hmm benefit
of the doubt yeah yeah
[Music]